Hello, students. My
name is Dustin Popp. I'm
a research scholar,
class of 2027, and I'm
here to give you a
lecture today on the
anatomy and the physiology
of the neocortex.
Before I begin, I
just want to thank
Dr. Ramos for guiding
me and helping
me with the creation
of this lecture.
These are the session
objectives for you
to read on your own
time. However, we
will go through all
of this in a lecture.
So we're going to talk
about the neocortex
today, but this is a
very basic slide just
for you to get the
basic understanding of
what we're looking at
here. The neocortex,
well, put it this way,
the frontal lobe, the
temporal lobe, the
parietal lobes just
posterior to the central
sulcus, as well as
the occipital lobe
have neocortex in them.
And the neocortex
usually consists of six
layers that are organized
into sulky, gyri,
and these two together
create our lobes of
those respective parts
of the brain, right?
And we'll go into
detail about each
of those parts, the
frontal, the temporal,
the occipital,
as well as the
parietal lobe. As
you can see, frontal,
temporal, occipital,
there's a cerebellum,
we're not going
to get into that
today. But we'll
go through all of
those parts, frontal,
temporal, parietal,
occipital lobe,
and what they do,
a little bit about
their functioning.
And the point I'd
like to make here is
that that's not all
of what the neocortex
is and does.
There's plenty more
areas that we aren't
going to talk about
in this PowerPoint,
and it would take
well over a week to
discuss everything.
And looking at these
stains here, this is
unstained, and what we
see are two different
cell types, but two
different things that
you could pick up on
visually. And what you
see here is the gray
matter. These are the
cell bodies of neurons
that then project axons,
which is this white
matter here, to various
other parts of the
cortex or subcortical
structures. So what we
see here is the gray
matter are the cell
bodies that are on the
peel surface, and the
white matter are the
axons of those cell
bodies going deep,
crossing the corpus
callosum or whatever, etc.
And moving forward,
this is a Nissel
stain, so the Nissel
stain actually stains
those cell bodies,
the gray matter
specifically, on the
peel surface, leaving
the white matter
tracks untouched.
However, you have
an axonal stain here
that does stain
the white matter
tracks while leaving
the neuronal cell
bodies unstained,
and this is an MRI.
Moving on to the
cytoarchitecture
of the neocortex,
this simply means
this is the cellular
architecture.
So like I said before,
usually there are
six layers of the
neocortex. You can see these
concentric sort of
layers. You can make
them out slightly. It
goes from six at the
deepest, and one is
the most superficial.
Layer one having
very few neurons, and
just mostly those
are axons in there.
and you can see this
is a gyrus that goes
into a sulcus that
comes into another gyrus
and the combination
of these things make
out lobes and in this
box here you can actually
visualize some
pyramidal cells which
we'll see a zoom in on
in the next slide and
this is zoom in that
you have pyramidal cells
here one two three and
four they look like
little pyramids if
you will they have a
triangular shape at
least. And these pyramidal
neurons make and
release glutamate, and
they have spiny
dendrites, as you can see
here. They also make
up 85% of the cortical
neurons in the neocortex.
The other 15% of
the neurons in the
cortex are not visualized
here. You'll need
a different type of
stain to visualize
them. Those are our non
-pyramidal neurons that
make and release GABA,
and they have non-spiny
dendrites usually.
Interestingly enough,
to think about all
of the cells, 75% of
all of the cells in
the neocortex are
actually glia cells, which
include astrocytes,
oligodendrocytes, and
microglia. And you
see a circled image of
this picture here,
these little dots. And
those glial cells,
the supporting cells,
actually make up
or actually greater
greater number in
population than total
neurons. It's
just something
interesting to think
about. You have more
supporting cells
than actual neurons.
And in this case, you
have here an axon.
This is a dendrite,
and this is an
axon going to
subcortical white matter.
And there are four
prototypical types
of connections that
are made by excitatory
neurons in the
neocortex. You have
very local, this is
number one example,
local cortical cortical
connections that
can occur within one
area or within layers
of a specific area
of the neocortex.
Two, you might have
longer range cortical
cortical areas that
might go from one
lobe to another, maybe
frontal to temporal,
for example, on the
same hemisphere.
Three, for example, this
is a interhemispheric
or colossal connection
that connects these
connections generally
connect to homotypic
areas on opposite sides
of the hemisphere.
We'll get into that a
little bit over here.
And four is a connection
from the cortex
to subcortical
structures like the
thalamus, the tectum,
and the basal ganglia,
as well as your
limbic system as well.
So you can see how
that's how sort of
maybe your thinking
area of your frontal
cortex might make
connections with emotional
structures, such as
the limbic system.
In these two
pictures, what we
see here is you
see a dye is
injected into
the gray matter,
the neurons of a
particular side of
the motor cortex
in a rodent here.
And the dye takes up,
the cell bodies take
up the dye, and the
dye then travels along
the axons of those
neurons and travels to
the the targets of those
axons so for example
the cell bodies of
the motor cortex in
example one here have
axons that project to the
contralateral motor
cortex as well as the
caudate and parts of
the basal ganglia and
what you're seeing
here is the dye's dye
fills the neurons at the
site of the injection
and labels the axon
targets of those neurons
you see a very similar
picture here dye
is inserted into the
somatosensory cortex
and the dye travels
along the axons you can
see highlighting the
axonal projections of
those neurons in the
somatosensory cortex
as it projects to the
contralateral cortex
as well as the thalamus
and in a zoomed in
picture here you see
those the dye highlighting
these axons from those,
the contralateral
neurons that were
injected with the dye.
And with all of these
connections, you can
start to see how one
area of the brain might
be connected to another
area of the brain.
And these connections
underpin the
biology that drive
complex human
behavior, such as
emotional regulation,
as well as sensual
motor integration.
And trying to
figure out all these
connections and what
they do, it can make it
very hard understand
what neural pathways
are responsible for
certain behaviors
emotions or feelings
and an example i bring
up is what neuronal
pathways could be
aberrant in generalized
anxiety disorder
and going forward here
and understanding the
difference in the
cytoarchitecture of
different lobes and gyrae
and sulci in various
parts of the neocortex
as well as using
functional maps will help
us understand how the
neocortex works and
for example um you have
the central sulcus
here that divides which
is sulcus that divides
the motor cortex
from the somatosensory
cortex and the point
of this slide is really
for you to realize
that you can have different
cellular histology
different cytoarchitecture
in different
lobes of the brain
that have their own
respective function.
And this is sort of what
Broadman was getting
into back in the 1900s.
He identified about
50 areas based on
histology of the tissue,
and those histology
maps relatively
accurately match onto
different tissue
functions as well. For
example, the neocortex
is designed and
looks a specific way
in the auditory cortex
compared to, let's
say, Broca's area,
which would be located
roughly over here.
The cells look
different, and Brodman
understood that,
and he classified
them with different
Brodman areas.
And thus, they also have
different
functions as well.
Another example of
this is that there's a
very unique cell type
visualized here with
Nguyen stain, which is
a neuronal biomarker.
And what you see
is that this is
what we call a
BEDS neuron, and
they're particularly
unique to the layer
5b of the primary
motor cortex.
Notice they're very
big neurons, and they
send projections via
the corona radiata
to the corticospinal
tract. And this is
an example of a unique
cytoarchitecture
component of the
motor cortex that is
only found in one
layer of the neocortex.
and for example this
type of cell will will
not be found in the
auditory cortex so
that's that's the whole
point of this slide
is realizing that there
are different cells
different cell types
different cytoarchitectural
designs that exist
in different lobes
of the brain that tie
into the different
functions of those
areas now in terms of
learning about the
different parts of the
human neocortex and
what they do, we have
four major ways that
we could learn about
this. This is technically
something called
functional neuroanatomy.
And the first is we
can have clinical case
reports. These are
documented brain
injuries, neoplasm, or
vascular events that
occur in a specific area
of the brain with a
correlated behavioral
and clinical deficit.
For example, injuries,
lesions to Wernicke's
and Broca's area
creating two different
types of aphasia. Bernke
is causing receptive
aphasia and Broca
is causing a spoken
or conductive aphasia.
And injury to a
specific area naturally
provides a clue of the
function of that area.
This unfortunately
requires rigorous
histopathology as
well as sophisticated
MRI imaging and
not all injury or
pathology is similar
in extent or location
among different
patients so the
results can be
difficult to interpret.
You could also use
functional MRI.
Functional MRI
measures brain activity
based on increasing
blood flow to a
specific area of
the brain, and it's
useful for learning
about brain activity
in specific regions
during behavioral
sensory as well
as motor tasks.
A limitation is
that the behavior is
limited in an MRI
environment as well
as the resolution
can be limited.
And functional MRI
can only capture
activity of groups of
neurons, and it can't
record the activity
of a single neuron.
You could also
use electric brain
stimulation. This
can be coupled with
behavioral observation
during neurosurgery.
We'll actually see some
examples of this in
some videos later on
that I will show you.
And the stimulation
is probably
being performed
during surgery for
a tumor or
epilepsy treatment,
And it can help the
person also know
what pathways to
avoid during surgery.
For example,
don't cut Broca's
area when sizing
a lymphoma.
And the cons of this
is that there are
limited regions that
can be sampled. And
usually patients
undergoing this, they don't
have healthy brains.
They might have
had a ******, a tumor,
or it's not necessarily
like a healthy
control, if you will.
And you could also do
electrical recording
of neuronal activity
during a cognitive
behavioral task,
and the recording is
probably performed
during surgery for a
tumor or epilepsy,
like electrical brain
stimulation, and
limitations that these
patients usually don't
have healthy brains.
now moving forward
we're going to start to
talk about some of the
respective lobes and
their functions and
we'll start from the
front we'll go talk
about the frontal cortex
and as you guys probably
know already the
frontal lobe is involved
in executive function
voluntary motor function
as well as speech
emotion and cognition
and to actually
define what executive
function are is You could
describe it as including
but not limited
to setting and maintaining
goals, planning,
a sense of delayed
gratification,
organizing, planning,
initiating, inhibiting
certain behaviors
in certain settings,
as well as self
-moderating, evaluating,
thinking about yourself,
acting strategically,
problem-solving, shifting
between cognitive
and effective
cognitive and affective
sets as well as
controlling your cognitive
functions and managing
moment to moment
events so things
that sort of make us
be able to operate at
job at jobs between
people interacting
between individuals
between peers this is
the area of the brain
that's highly active
in all of this Um,
and also to remind
you, uh, you have the
premotor cortex as well
as supplemented motor
areas that are in
the frontal lobe and
which means that the
frontal lobe can have
a role in the planning
and organization and
the exact executing
complex motor tasks.
And I would like to
note that the prefrontal
cortex is really
specifically involved in
a lot of these executive
function tasks,
while more posteriorly
of the part of the
frontal lobe is the
motor cortex. So just a
little bit of nuance
there, but just no frontal
lobe. I'm not really
going to be testing
you specifics about
the prefrontal cortex.
And the frontal
lobe, Since it's
involved in those
higher-order functions,
such as emotional
regulation,
empathy, planning,
etc., you can imagine
that injury or illness
to the frontal lobe
can affect mood as well
as can cause certain
psychopsychiatric
diseases. A very famous
example of this is
that you have Philly
Phineas Gage, who got
a piece of iron struck
through his orbital
frontal cortex. He was
once a loving husband
and father, and after
the incident, he
became short-tempered,
brash, and he was prone
to devise and then
abandon any plans he
made. And this is a
great case study example
of where you have
frontal lobe injury
to a specific part of
your brain that leads
to various changes in
personality, affect,
and social behavior.
Another instance where
you could have illness
or a tumor causing a
psychiatric condition
is with frontal lobe
meningiomas, which
are growths of the
meninges, tumor of the
meninges. And the
meningeal overgrowth is
compressing, damaging,
changing biochemistry
of the neurons in the
frontal cortex, and
maybe some of those
neurons are involved
with executive
function, and it's not
uncommon for patients with
frontal lobe meningiomas
to have depression
or schizophrenia
or other some type of
psychiatric disorder.
on the right here
uh back into the 30s
frontal lobotomy was
developed to treat
psychiatric illnesses
such as schizophrenia
by severing connections
to the frontal
lobe and we see two
mris here where you have
some parts of the
frontal lobe that were
cut out right and the
procedure was very
effective in blending
mood and affect
and relieving clinical
symptoms especially
in suicidal patients,
but it's no longer
used due to advances
in pharmacotherapy,
as well as moral and
ethical needs. I'm
sure you might
hear about this in
another lecture,
but we'll mention it
here. We're talking
about a frontal
temporal dimension,
a behavioral variant.
And what you can make
of it is that what
you see in this image
here, this is normal,
where you see very
healthy, sulky gyri and
it doesn't look like
there's much atrophy
in this patient's
frontal lobe as well as
their temporal lobe
however in this patient
in the ftd patient you
can see significant
atrophy in the frontal
lobe you can see
thinning of gyri and
widening of the sulci
and that is reflective
of a disease process
here, which is caused
by these mutations in
MAPT, which encodes
for tau. And you can
see these tau aggregates
here on the side.
And it makes sense
that damage and atrophy
to the cells of the
frontal as well as the
temporal lobe will
cause some of these
symptoms here, like
deficits in executive
function, such as poor
decision-making, judgment,
problem-solving,
organization skills.
Patient will have
difficulty planning the
day's activities. They
may make questionable
financial decisions
and have on-the
-job mistakes. There's
usually a lack of
inhibition, so the
patient has disinnovative
behavior, such as loss
or lack of restraint
based on social
norms. This can lead
to inappropriate
behavior and impulsivity.
The behaviors can
include making
uncharacteristic
or rude or
offensive comments.
Boards love this,
ignoring other people's
social or personal space,
reckless spending,
touching strangers or
inappropriate ******
behavior, as well as
aggressive outbursts
and apathy. An
interesting point is
that the disease onset
is between 45 and
65 it's slightly
younger than alzheimer's
patients the page
could also have
indifference or lack of
interest in previously
meaningful activities
as well as a
neglected personal
hygiene you could have a
loss of initiative
emotional blunting loss
of warmth or empathy
or concern for
others and you can
see that this disease
not only affects the
individual but everyone
that this patient
is associated with
We're not going to
spend much time on
this. I believe you
guys had some of
this in another
lecture, but the frontal
lobe area 8, which
you see here and you
see here, is vital
for rapid saccadic
voluntary eye movement.
This area sends
axonal projections
to the PPRF, the
paramedian pontine
reticular formation.
This is in the pons.
And the PPRF then
sends projections
to the abducens
nuclei as well
as the ocular motor
nerve nuclei to
carry out voluntary
eye movement.
And what you see is that
electrical recordings
show action potentials
in area 8. before
eye movements moving
on to the primary
motor cortex what we
see is that it's the
pre-central gyrus here
just anterior to our
central sulcus and
this produces voluntary
movements and it sends
projections to the
spinal cord and you
know it from the
homunculus you have a
lot more neurons devoted
to moving a finger
in face musculature
due to over a highly
large representation
on the homunculus
compared to let's say
somewhere on like for
the knee for example
the afferents come from
motor vestibular and
sensory systems like
catching a football
with your hands or
catching yourself from
tripping down the
stairs and the efferents
project to the thalamus
the brain stem the
spinal cord as well as
the basal ganglion for
voluntary motor
movements and electrical
stimulation will cause
muscle twitches so if
i hook an electrode
up to the medial part
of the primary motor
cortex where your hip
is, you could stimulate
hip flexion there.
And what's cool is that
in patients with an
intact motor cortex,
but with a spinal cord
injury, so paralyzed
patients that may have
undergone or suffered
trauma to their
spinal cord, and they
might be effectively
paralyzed, but their
motor cortex is intact,
what you we can do is
you can encode neuronal
activity from motor
areas and put that
information into a
computer and that computer
can then take that
encoded intention from
the patient's motor
cortical areas and can
tell a prosthetic limb
to then move to what
the patient wants the
oral prosthetic arm to
do thus bypassing the
patient's spinal cord
and what we'll see is
some videos of this
so the patient's
controlling the arm and
angling it all with
intention from her motor
cortex the intention
for those actions is
being recorded from her
motor cortex sent into
a computer that then
encodes those commands
and tells the arm to
do what she wants.
Moving forward, we're
going to talk about
the cortical anatomy
of speech production.
And there's this man
named Paul Pierre
Broca, and he's what
we name Broca's aphasia
aft for. And what
you see here, this is
Broca's area involved
in speech production.
People who have
strokes to this area
or trauma may
suffer from what we
call Broca's aphasia
or expressive
aphasia, where they
can't form words,
yet they will still
understand them.
And what's interesting
you see is that
this is your motor
strip, and you have
motor control of the
mouth and lips right
here, and very close
to it is Broca's
area. So that sort
of makes sense that
these two areas are
close to each other,
and they might be
related in function.
And notice also
you have Wernicke's
area over here as
well as your angular
gyrus which we'll
get into later.
And it's also
important to realize
that Broca's area
receives inputs
from auditory as
well as motor areas.
Auditory being over here
and motor being
over here.
So now we've hopped
over the central
sulcus. Now we're in
the postcentral gyrus
which contains our
primary somatosensory
cortex, which is S1,
and this is involved
in higher-order
sensory processing
as well as visual and
spatial attention.
And as we see here,
very similarly with
the motor cortex,
there's a lot of
more neurons devoted
to sensation for
skin on the fingers
as well as the face.
Now, talking about
issues with the parietal
lobe, specifically
right posterior
parietal lobe damage
will cause a spatial hemi
neglect so what is
that so a hemi neglect
is a lack of attention
towards one side
of the body and one
side of the world so
usually the left side
uh patients will put
clothes or makeup on
on one side of the
body note this is
not a visual problem
there's nothing wrong
with the visual pathways
that you have gone
over this is simply
an issue of a higher
level processing of
the aferent incoming
sensory stimuli from
the occipital lobe.
So the parietal lobe
is just not appraising
the visual information
that the occipital
lobe has created.
It's usually seen
with large lesions to
the right, usually
non-dominant posterior
parietal lobe, and
the artery supplying
this brain region
is the right MCA.
The right posterior
parietal lobe
is involved in
spatial processing
for both left
and right sides.
And the right
posterior parietal lobe
seems to play a
role in visual
appraisal and attention
to the world around
us. And the primary
visual cortex
has projections to
the parietal lobe,
which you'll probably
see in another lecture.
And we'll go through some
of these images here.
So what we have
here is this is
a model, and the
patient is asked
to copy the model
on the left.
And the patient tries
to copy that model
from memory, but what
they only draw is
only the right side of
all of these images,
only the right
side of the clock,
the right side
of the house,
of the flower.
Here, the patient
is asked to draw
lines through the
middle sections of
these lines as it's
done here. However,
only the right
side is done. There
is a hemi-neglect of
the left side here
as there's no
lines through them.
and i would like to
note here all the tests
that are shown are
administered by putting
up the paper right in
front of their face
so that let the left
and right visual fields
can be assessed when
this is done the
patient only fills out
one side of the paper
likely crossing like
likewise in crossing
the lines or in the
circle stars task here
right so the patient's
shown this but they're
only circling on the
right side so it's
not that they're not
seeing this they're
just not appraising that
this visual information
is there, and they're
not circling it.
Another part of
the parietal lobe
is the angular
gyrus, and you
see the angular
gyrus right here,
and lesions to the
angular gyrus, which
is part of the
inferior parietal lobe,
can lead to agraphia
as well as alexia, and
agraphia is deficits
in writing, and alexia
deficits in reading
words, and this area is
also vital for assigning
meaning to words.
The angular gyrus is what
we call a heteromodal
association area,
meaning that integrates
sensory information
from visual, auditory,
as well as other
sensory areas. It helps
link areas the brain
associated with memory,
spatial cognition,
and language together.
And the angular
gyrus shows increased
activity in fMRI during
reading and writing.
and damage to the
angular gyrus can
also cause mouth
calculation issues,
and we see the
angular gyrus here.
Now, like we said before,
damage to the left
angular gyrus is
actually called Gerstmann
syndrome, and this
occurs when there's
a ****** or injury to
the dominant hemisphere
affecting the left
inferior parietal lobe
in the region of the
left angular gyrus,
And this consists of
four clinical signs,
dysgraphia, agraphia,
leading to
writing deficits,
dyscalculia,
leading to impaired
arithmetic
calculation abilities.
You could have right
and left disorientation,
which is difficulty
identifying right
versus left side of
your body, as well as
finger agnosia, which
is the inability to
distinguish or identify
individual fingers.
I'm not going to
talk much about the
occipital lobe. We've
had a lot of lectures
relating to visual
pathways, but what
we see here is that
the occipital lobe is
involved in receiving
visual information
and creating images
from what we see.
And what we see here
is the occipital
lobe is sending
projections to the
posterior parietal
lobe as well as
the inferior temporal
cortex here. So
what we see is that
the occipital lobe is
projecting to these
higher-order processing
areas for that information
to be processed.
Moving on to the
temporal lobe, the
temporal lobe has roles
in audition, as well
as memory and
higher-order visual
processing, as well
as spatial navigation.
So you can stick
a taxi cab driver
in an fMRI, and
you can ask them to
think about
navigating the streets
of Manhattan or
wherever they are,
getting from point
A to point B.
And what you'll
see is that as
they're thinking
about their route,
the temporal
lobe, both of them
most likely, will
actually show
increased blood
flow on an fMRI.
The temporal
lobe contains the
primary auditory
cortex, damage to
which leads to
auditory deficits.
You could also have
a Wernicke's area is
also in the temporal
lobe here, right?
And damage to the
Wernicke's area can
cause a Wernicke's
aphasia, which is the
inability to comprehend
spoken language.
This can often lead
to confabulation.
And another important
note about the temporal
lobe is it helps us
listen to speech and
then respond properly
with fluid language.
And what we see
here is this arcuate
fasciculus is a white
matter tract that
connects Wernicke's
area to Broca's area.
Moving forward,
like we said before,
the temporal lobe has
a role in audition,
memory, higher
order visual
processing, as well
as spatial navigation.
And a specific part
of the temporal lobe
is the fusiform face
area, fusiform gyrus.
And damage to this
specific area will
actually lead to something
called prosopagnosia,
which is the
inability to recognize
faces after damage to
this area. So the patient
will be shown a
face, but they will
describe it as a blur
or something else, and
they won't be able
to recognize the face
of that person, but
they will still be
able to recognize the
voice of that person.
That's a different
neuronal pathway
that is left untouched.
And interestingly
enough, these
areas in the
temporal lobe show
increased activation
following the
presentation of faces.
But specifically,
we'll just talk
about the FFA,
causing prosopagnosia.
And here is an
example of this.
Electrical implants
are placed in this
patient's fusiform
face area, the FFA, And
the stimulation
will perturb this
patient's neuronal
physiology and will lead
to a distortion of
the physician's face.
something else.
Your whole face is
sort of metamorphosed.
Did it get warped? Yes.
Did it shape?
Now going off of
the temporal lobe,
we'll specifically
talk about the medial
temporal lobe,
which does include
our hippocampus
here. You see that
cinnamon bun-like
shape for hippocampus.
The medial temporal
lobe is particularly
vulnerable to injury
after head trauma,
and what you see is
a tau staining can be
actually used as a
neuronal injury marker.
And this is a healthy
brain, a normal
brain, while this is
unfortunately the brain
of a pro football
player, and you can see
a lot of tau staining
indicating neuronal
injury in a lot of these
areas, specifically
an area devoted to
memory, like the
hippocampus and the
medial temporal lobe.
In addition, the
medial temporal lobe is
vulnerable to injury
in Alzheimer's disease.
And I mentioned this
here, whether tau
accumulation is
the cause of memory
loss or some event
preceding tau creation
is essentially
unknown at this point.
Why I say this is
because we are now
using monoclonal
antibodies to help try to
clear out tau in
Alzheimer's patients.
And one would think
that this would
completely reverse the
memory loss scene if
you completely clear
out tau. However,
this is not necessarily
the case even
after treatment with
some of these drugs.
Yes, they lower the
tau burden, but you
don't have complete
recovery of memory.
Memory doesn't return
back to baseline.
So it's possible that
the issue leading to
memory loss may occur
upstream to tau creation.
But that, like I
said, is under a heavy
amount of research at
this point in time.
However, using
monoclonals to help clear
out plaques is useful
for patients still.
And the damage to
the neurons here is
correlated with memory
loss and function. This
is a normal patient
with healthy medial
temporal lobe. While
this is a patient with
Alzheimer's, you can see
much more tau staining
reflecting these are
dying neurons here.
Two other lobes
we'll talk about are
the insular cortex, as
well as the cingulate
cortex here, right
on the midline.
And less is known
about these areas
compared to primary
sensory areas.
Here is the insula,
you have the
anterior part of
the insula, as well
as the posterior
part of the insula.
so the insular cortex
is involved in various
amount of myriad of
functions including
gustation olfaction
vestibular sensations
pleasure reward addiction
as well as visceral
and autonomic
functions and this the
insular cortex receives
input related to
those areas we'll get
into in a little bit.
It's also a hub for
interoception and
translates interoceptive
inputs into conscious
feelings. And damage
to the interlobe can
cause various different
clinical pictures.
So in this huge diagram,
which you do not
have to memorize at
all, what you see is
information like
body pain, visceral
pain, temperature,
metabolism,
tissue stress,
etc., head pain,
touch, tongue,
taste, not touch,
tongue, tasting,
et cetera,
as well as visceral
information from your
heart, lungs, your
gut, your kidney, et
cetera, all essentially
get funneled
through various different
pathways to different
parts of the
insula that sort of
appraise and comprehend
all of this information,
this visceral and
autonomic information
from all these
different organs it's
also important to
realize that the insular
cortex is activated
in taste in ransom
food as well as stimuli
that are deemed to
be morally disgusting
and uh this is seen
uh via fmri and i got
this from a book that
i'm reading by robert
sapolsky he's a dr
robert sapolsky he's
a neuroscientist and
um yeah i just think
that's This is pretty
interesting how the
insular cortex, which
was evolved a while
ago, millions of years
ago, to help us taste
rancid food. When
you would taste rancid
food, the insular
cortex would light
up, and this would
stimulate a mammal's
version of vomiting.
However, as we've
developed and as a society,
if this area of
the brain will also
light up, if a patient
deems something to
be morally disgusting,
for example,
if you stick a
patient in an fMRI and
have them think about
violence, murder,
etc., things like
that, this area will
actually light up. And
it's just interesting
how evolution doesn't
necessarily create new
structures, it just
sort of adds on to
what's already available
for it. And in this
case, the insular cortex
added this function
of being activated
with moral disgust.
interestingly enough
damage to the insular
cortex in this 2007
paper really helped
patients decrease
their drive to smoke
cigarettes the insula
is necessary for the
ability to consciously
appreciate and
derive pleasure and
it's also necessary for
the sensation of
urges like to like to
smoke in smokers. That
urge is very strong.
And what you see
here is that damage
to the insular lobe,
you can see here,
actually makes the
drive to smoke much
less. And this is
exciting because this
could be a possibly
a new area to target
with novel drugs or
TMS in the future.
And what we see
here is a patient
undergoing
neurosurgery and their
insular cortex is
being stimulated.
And I'll play this
video for you.
It was a little low.
I apologize for that.
But essentially what
happened was she
received a lower dose
stimulation initially
and she reported tasting
chocolate. But as
the intensity increased,
as well as the
duration of the
stimulus, you can see the
expression on her face
turn to disgust as she
believes she tasted
bad chocolate with the
stimulation. And
that is an example of
one of the functions
of the insular cortex.
Moving on to the
cingulate cortex, the
cingulate cortex has
roles in cognition,
emotion, memory,
as well as the
four Fs, which are
feeding, fighting,
flighting, and
fornicating.
You can see the
cingulate cortex here
as part of the papus
circuit, sending
projections to the
hippocampus while
receiving sensory
information from the
thalamus and other
sensory areas here.
Interestingly enough,
patients who have drug
-resistant depression
or OCD could
potentially benefit
from a bilateral
anterior cingulotomy.
This is taken
from a patient one
week after surgery.
You can see two
lesions here in the
anterior cingulate,
as well as right
here and here.
You could also use
a bilateral anterior
cingulotomy for the
treatment of chronic pain.
This patient here
suffered from
metastatic bone pain,
which was completely
eliminated after
surgery, and
the effect remained
for 20 months.
And the surgery
is safe and can be
effective depending
on numerous factors.
cingulotomies can also
be considered for post
-herpetic neurology
as well as trigeminal
neurology and this is
just showing you that
you have Columbia
University as Presbyterian
in the city that do
cingulotomies currently
and this here is
just an example of
if you stimulate the
anterior cingulate
cortex you could induce
laughter As you can
see, this individual
is given a dose of
electricity, and you
can see them smile.
So that is about
all I have today.
We covered a lot. We
talked about
the neocortex.
We talked about the
side architecture
of the neocortex,
as well as different
types of cells
that exist in the
neocortex. We talked
about different
cortical areas,
including the sensory
areas, motor areas,
and cognitive areas.
And we talked about
connections between
areas and within
these areas as well.
And we also talked
about how particular
stimulation or
damage to a brain
area can affect and
change behavior.
So I'll go over one
question with you,
maybe two, depending on
how much time I have.
um there are about
four or five questions
in here um feel free
to do them and get back
to me if you have any
questions about them
but here 55 year old
man is brought into
the family medicine
clinic because of a recent
change in behavior
over the last two years
once a sweet and
reserved man the patient
is now yelling obscene
comments at his co
-workers on the job his
wife also reports that
he has gotten much ruder
and less empathetic
to her needs over
the last two years he
has also spent $40
,000 in the last month
gambling. What is the
most likely diagnosis
and the gene associated
with the diagnosis?
Pause it if you
need, and the
answer is, this
is an example
of frontal
temporal dementia.
Next question. A 38
-year-old man gets hit
in the head by a rock
that was thrown at
him. It is noticed
that the man cannot
voluntarily move his
eyes from side to side.
What brain area is
most likely affected?
The frontal area 8,
like we talked about.
And last question,
I'll go over. A patient
suffers an ischemic
****** in the right
MCA about a week
after the ****** while
the patient's recovering
in the hospital.
A family member noticed
the patient only
eating food on the
right side of his
plate. When asked to
draw a clock, he does
this. what is the
most likely diagnosis.
This is an example of
hemispatial neglect.
That's all I'll go
over. If you guys have
any questions, please
let me know. Thank
you for your time and
have a lovely day.